all right today we're gonna be doing
things a little bit differently so if
you don't know where it was happening
Kai became the biggest twitch streamer
on the platform good for him
congratulations
thank you
number one I was sleeping I kept hearing
my notifications and when I looked he
was like 79 and it comes and I'm like
I'm so happy for you baby
yes sir so much and we we watching I'll
be so proud of you everybody babe I love
you so much babe I'm so proud of you
you're number one
and I'm so happy to be your mom
know that you've been working hard and
that's what the world know that you've
been working hard like this for a long
time
just fighting out my son worked hard
he's a grinder every day every night and
and he gives me the world and I want the
world
congratulations okay
hey I love you too
I've been at it for a few years good
good for you surpassed everybody good
for him and he's a little extra extra
Kai's not exactly favored by the
platform
it's not for everybody to platform you
know how they have their Golden Boys
yeah Ty's not their gold I mean the
platform don't like Kai
they don't show him love the way they
show much smaller streamers love but of
course that's a different topic we're
not getting it I'm just saying despite
that he made it that far
yeah good for him so as I'm saying
excellent that's all when you're like
first or second generation and you try
to do something that kind of breaks the
mold parents are especially against it
because they don't even understand a lot
of this online stuff now thankfully for
this younger generation I think younger
parents are probably seeing it a bit
differently uh but I know from my mom it
took me a long time before I ever told
her I did anything and even the way I
told her was mad weird just for the fun
of it so uh it's a story you're a whole
jackass but that has a story for a
different day but I thought I thought it
was really cool
seeing him kind of reach a lot of his
goals and for his mom to show him that
love and adulation and for him to feel
that kind of like cathartic moment
that's really cool man it's cool to see
that stuff and in a week with so much
weird stuff on Twitch or YouTube or
whatever it's kind of just cool to see
folks be able to achieve certain things
and be rewarded with it be rewarded not
by like monetary gain or numbers but
just by like something simple like
your mom is proud of you anything that
happens that's it think about that he
reached the largest thing and the moment
he cries is his mom says I'm proud of
you that's when it really hits
at the end of the day that's a really
human moment and beyond all these
numbers and stuff like that I think we
all kind of want that
to hear that from our parents hear that
from you know our mentors or whatever it
might be and uh he got to see that and
we all got to witness it you know me
generally I'm not I'm not the biggest
person with like seeing sentimental
personal stuff but I'm not gonna lie
that [ __ ] was pretty cool so good for
you
it's kind of a word for all the parents
out there um
first generation that is out somewhere
you came here
for us to be able to do that
you you came when my parents came here
they wanted me
to have a better life a better thing but
it's also to not be able to live in
stress and to actually to live that
to be able to do that and the problem
sometimes that I have with first
generation parents is that they only
congratulate you
or push you or encourage you
when the dollars come in or where your
your name starts to drop out when people
see you or where their friends are like
oh I've seen your son I've seen your son
I've seen him oh he that's where you
congratulate us and that's a bit I
understand why I understand the whole
thing don't come up in the comments like
it's because I know why but
yeah
it's a bit [ __ ]
because all this time we'll be talking
about diversity and we want diversity
but we have to look at ourselves and be
like you know what we have to push for
kids doing different things
yeah like growing up I got some of my
people from my friends that we're doing
theater
I know it's not all the first generation
parents come in here pushing their kids
to do theater
but once it's only once you hit and
you're big and your name is out there
and your last name is there and being
said loudly that you're like oh yeah
that's my son okay yeah but I have to
struggle with you to do that
so it's fun that you congratulate and
I'm not saying that's what cake Kai uh
as mom is it did I I don't know that I I
don't know that the relationship they
have I knew nothing about that I'm not
saying that that's what she did I'm
saying that it makes me reflect about
other parents that are not pushing
their kids so yeah you came here for me
to be able to do that
so let me yeah
Kai becoming one of the biggest uh
streamers on the platform good for you
bacon history especially at his age
that's what how old is he ah they use
like 22 23. do you think
congratulations that's fantastic I think
him and there's another one on YouTube I
show speed which is like hitting like
100k viewer streamers and like biggest
I'll do on the platform and that was
dude who also got banned from twitch
you know so it's interesting seeing like
these young black dudes just kill to
this level and be this popular and not
necessarily get that kind of love from
the platform but still finding ways to
reach people directly
um I respect I respect it really why is
it weird
it's not so much the same thing where
I'm heading at because we we here don't
get recognized but we we killing it
right sure we don't get we went over to
our top tens and come back with nowhere
to be found and I kind of feel the same
thing but like I feel that's a lot of
places where it's like hey yeah yeah
whatever you got it yeah the platform
doesn't give a [ __ ] that much you know
yeah so so I don't know
I'll be happy
that's a whole different discussion
that's your word hey man
hey man that's your word again damn it
hey Elizabeth congratulations at the end
of the day that's what really matters
you're getting the big old dub and I
remember we covered a video on him a
while back where he's doing these pranks
and you know people felt like we were
trying to cancel listen I don't want
nobody removed off this platform no
nobody to lose their voice I want people
to go on and make their money and do
whatever they want to do who cares so
the same way maybe we'll be like ah I
think that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
getting your dubs get them get your get
your get your wins we want people to
strive at the end of the day even if we
have strong disagreements with people we
don't want them to lose their ability to
take care of their family or whatever it
might be so you know good for him good
for him and you know what I'll say it's
really cool to see the face of a lot of
these platforms change even though the
platform doesn't want it to be that way
it's not they don't decide the people
are deciding people the people are
really like riding with these guys
they're going to watch whatever the [ __ ]
people are going to watch yeah because
recently like um the sidemen ran like a
charity event over out in the UK
actual speed was invited to be part of
the soccer charity match they raised
over a million quid for a charity in one
day stream blew the numbers out the door
um
but it's dope it's dope because even
though this kid's 18 years old you know
garnering all this leadership he goes
overseas and he gets just as much if not
more love and so it's cool to see how
these folks are making a new wave and
taking over the platform having fun
doing it their way so yeah I don't know
for me it's just enjoyable to see the
canceled thing I think was really just a
clickbait thing uh and people are also
not used to disagreeing with people they
really think that because you disagree
with someone you hate them and you want
them out no I could disagree with
someone I could think someone's take is
act super stupid and so be like do your
thing at the end of the day he does him
I also think what he did was what it was
and we said what he said and that's fine
but you get you get you get a win you
get a win that's that's fine that's why
I want me you got to get used to
disagreeing with people there's people
like because they're your friends
everything they say is the truth and is
right and you got because you're friends
with them you got to agree with
everything they said or else it looks
you sound like you're a betrayer you
know you sound like you're a traitor
like oh no I don't no no you're supposed
to have my back now what you did was
stupid whether you're my friend or
you're not my friend if I thinking some
[ __ ] is stupid it's dumb it's [ __ ]
it is what he did number of times we
worked together number of times you told
me that [ __ ] that I did with that's dumb
stop and I was like yeah you know what
it was done and again and we kept on
going we kept it moving hey man listen I
just wanted to graduate I didn't want to
rehash whole stuff so I really don't
care to be possible shout out that's it
that's all I got go ahead but yeah
that's pretty much that's what that
that's just what I got from that people
saying that and [ __ ] it doesn't matter
and these platforms you know they got to
wake up they gotta they gotta change
their definition of what is brain safe
and what is not because these young
folks they don't care they got a whole
different view of the world and I'm not
gonna lie these young cats even though
they're edgy or they'd be a little bit
wild they're driving where the viewers
want to go you know they are what the
future looks like so [ __ ] got
to get behind that at some point that is
the future yeah you know we just got
trending the other day because of kids
now an old song by R Kelly they get I
don't remember but they get the design
they get to decide I mean listen
[Applause]
but they got some good taste I mean R
Kelly A classic I mean listen drip drip
drip he and he in jail you know what I'm
saying behind them watch bars but listen
congratulations these young kids don't
listen I don't care what nobody says R
Kelly put them behind bars but I'ma keep
stepping in the Name of Love You know
what I'm saying me and my lady we gonna
bump and grind you feel me we gotta keep
the classics oh my God Abba has a lady
I said me and my ladies
laughs